[Music]
Jeff and gain the traffic king and queen
are back baby the much anticipated
Epstein file has dropped it's 1,000
Pages only Cat Williams can read that
fast so here are the hits turns out the
Epstein Island conspiracy is some fresh
blood and no I'm not talking about Hyman
human Hot Wheels Steven Hawking got
rolled into this kid diddling debacle
Hawking who apparently loves strip clubs
and looked like he got a lap dance from
a wrecking ball visited Epstein's Island
for an academic conference in 2006 where
he was rumored to have an underage orgy
or as he calls it the Gang Bang Theory
Epstein tried to pay people to discredit
the rumor and cover up Hawkings tire
tracks They even tried to erase Steven's
memory by shaking him like an eter
sketch Hawking wasn't the only new name
revealed voice actor for a cartoon dirt
bike RFK Jr was on the list he
immediately blamed his ex-wife for being
on Epstein's plane and at his house
finally a Kennedy that knows how to use
his wife for cover Honestly though does
the CIA kill everyone this guy knows
look I just hope he wasn't at the Steven
Hawking orgy okay the kennedies have
seen enough brain splatter think about
it David Copperfield also was allegedly
at Epstein's house because when there's
kids to entertain you hire a magician
they actually asked Copperfield if he
wanted a 26-year-old to which he
responded in true magician fashion let's
cut that in half aside from those guys
it's just the same CTIC characters that
deserve to take a submarine trip to the
Titanic Bill Clinton was mentioned but
the worst thing they said about Bill in
the whole drop is he likes him young I
mean this guy is slipperier than Stephen
Hawkins chin as of now the only miners
that we know for sure Clinton
were the ones digging out of the rubble
in Haiti and you can't mention Epstein
without his favorite royal kid Rin
prince Andrew I mean how is this guy not
in jail oh yeah he's a Prince I
can't believe England pays for this guy
to fly around the world and teens
at least in America we elect people to
fly around the world and teens the
royal family claims that what prince
Andrew is doing is not grooming it's air
conditioning now if that joke is
confusing try spelling air h e i r
ultimately this drop was more useless
than Steven Hawkings Fitbit the
allegations are so old Clinton wouldn't
stuff his cocking him hopefully more
information comes out hopefully Justice
is served and hopefully Epstein and
gilain or jiz Lane orever the hell you
pronounce her name hopefully they both
rot in hell I mean that would be a
Massad with a happy ending now let's
start the
show